we will of course get to the doj special
Council that has been announced it is
starting all up again and I will tell
you what this likely means but before we
get to that I want to go to a completely
bizarre surreal clip
of loser Republican gubernatorial
candidate from Arizona Kerry Lake
she was at Mar-A-Lago for some kind of
event and she made a declaration she
says that she is going to fight what
happened in Arizona
now you know and I know that what
happened in Arizona is she lost
what happened in Arizona is the other
candidate Katie Hobbs got more votes
and when things work as planned the
candidate who gets more votes
becomes the governor
very difficult concept apparently for
Kerry Lake listen to this and she got
the heroes welcome and she's like we're
gonna fight this
oh my God
[Music]
they had to do everything they could to
stop us balance harvesting actually yeah
they had to vote they had to shut down
the machines on Election Day but we know
their tricks and they think they can
slow and pour cold water on a movement
now I want you all to understand she
says what they did was ballot harvesting
and to uh what was the word she said
turn off or slow down they had to do
everything they could to stop us balance
harvesting they had to shut down the
machines on Election Day ah right so the
issue she's citing that has some
substance is that there was an issue at
a few Maricopa County locations because
of a couple of malfunctioning machines
the machines were fixed and the
Republican Party originally filed the
lawsuit dropped their lawsuit because it
was all taken care of did not
substantively affect the election ballot
harvesting is just something they repeat
I don't even think they know what it
means but we know their tricks and they
think they can slow and pour cold water
on a movement it is not possible people
you cannot stop the American Spirit
you cannot stop the founding fathers one
person is clapping and the blood that we
have that we have inside of us and so I
will fight what happened on Tuesday of
what was it two weeks ago now where are
we two weeks in we we vote for a month
in Arizona we count both votes for two
weeks and look it's a joke our elections
are a circus run by clowns
I love that we are going to fight what
happened what does that even mean you
just lost how do you fight the fact that
you lost by lying and claiming that you
won so don't for a second
I I I don't want I know most people in
my audience would never fall for
something like this
don't even allow to enter your brain
that anything other than Katie Hobbs
becoming the governor is going to happen
in Arizona now maybe Carrie lake is
going to fight this by running for
governor again in the future if she's
not Trump's VP which she wants to be and
we'll get to that a little bit later but
all that happened is that she lost and
she wants to fight that
I don't think she's going to be
successful we talk about it all the time
one of the biggest contributors to
climate change is deforestation did you
know that 15 of deforestation is due to
toilet paper production alone according
to the nrdc that's why I love our
sponsor real paper real paper makes a
sustainable toilet paper no trees it
uses 100 bamboo a bamboo stock can keep
being harvested indefinitely no
deforestation real paper is certified by
the forest Stewardship Council for
responsible harvesting of the bamboo
grass used for their paper another
contributor to climate change the
plastic that the toilet paper comes
wrapped in that's why real paper
involves no plastic packaging and best
of all real paper looks and feels just
like normal traditional toilet paper the
cost is similar it is fan fantastic on
their website you can do a one-time
purchase or set up an easy recurring
subscription the way that I did my
audience gets 30 off your first order
plus free shipping go to realpaper.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman at
checkout the link is down below